dude look at Mike Lindell my pillow
[__] just
CR crushed under pressure you know
I love this I love you know I love the
my pillow and I don't they're not paying
me to say this dude the my pillows are
[__] I have five of them dude I I love
my pillow so much I sleep on them and
hold them I hold them like they're
[__] dogs and I go to sleep and I
can't without holding on my pillow I
hold my pillow so much in bed that my
wife's like why is there always a my
pillow between us and I'm like you want
me to get good sleep or not
the other night I said let's have sex
and she said I don't know if I really
feel like like and I go like this I
brought down my pillow out I put it in
between us she started laughing just a
little marriage humor you know
dude look at Mike Lindell
[__]
concave under a little bit of pressure
okay and I'm not asking about is this
one where there was
the word deposition with the the January
6th what the [__] did the my pillow guy
have to do with this by the way did he
put out information about it
I don't even know how'd they lumped a my
pillow guy in on this
January 6th [__]
yeah but like in what way is he part of
it
he always is always holding the pillow
who's trying who's [__] trusting him
who's believing a [__] he says isn't
this guy a comedy isn't he a character
he's a comedy character you can't put
him in jail for being like yeah it's an
Insurrection and we gotta go take back
the government he's on the [__]
pillow all the time I see these guys on
the pillow he's got a pill he's sitting
on a pill I swear to God in his
deposition he brought a pillow
the lumpy pillow called look at this
dude you do not this is like when he you
call his pillow lumpy that's like in
Biff and Back to the Future when you
call him chicken
dude look he takes off he goes to put
here he takes off his glasses when
somebody calls him a lumpy because of
pillow lumpy this is how you know how
gangsters is because he takes off the
glasses it's not just the fact that he
takes off the glasses is because
three seconds before them
she put them on dude so you knew he was
getting ready to like either read
something or chill with his glasses on
he put them on somebody called the
pillow lumpy he goes like this oh oh oh
oh [__] let's rewind some time
and I'm not asking about here we go put
some glasses on lumpy and I'm not lumpy
pillows that's not what they call him oh
dude honorary no no they're not lumpy
pillows that's not what they call them
so good
okay and I'm not asking about the lumpy
pillow calls no they're not lumpy
pillows that's not what they call on
okay that when you say lumpy pillows now
you're an [__] you got oh dude and
it's not enough to just call him an
[__] to drill the point home is
amazing watch it now you're an [__]
you got that confirming he understands
is the absolute game this dude honestly
is the Tony Soprano of betting and I I
I'm like this is unreal okay they're not
looking pillows all right and and and
and you know you call it an Olympic
pillow and that's what makes you an
[__]
do you got that
you're an [__] drilled at home what
you are like no he's an [__] nice
in contempt an [__] that's what you
are lumpy pillows kiss my ass
set
in contempt
put that in your book
oh dude put that in your book such a
white guy thing to say I want to put
that in your book huh damn any Christmas
foreign
they answer anything any problem
customer that wants to reach Mike
Lindell those are the ones dude like
he's Ricky Henderson it's so dope to do
yourself in third person when you sell
pillows
I want to talk to Mike Lindell I want to
talk to Mike Lindell they send them to
here and they go
or they call about um maybe they didn't
get their pillow on time because of uh
um the FedEx or whatever well we'll
cover them even though it could be that
somebody else's fault nobody calls
because of a lumpy pillow
but good good one though you're done
smash dumb dude guys says you're done
yeah I'm done now I like that I like
that he goes yeah I'm done
I liked that
now here's why I can't trust them
what I'm saying obviously you don't have
it yeah it wasn't done dude
wasn't done love it I'm done I'm done
and another thing dude the Tony Soprano
of betting yeah I'm done
here we go what I'm saying obviously you
don't have my pillow too product
placement dude uh you probably wouldn't
be in such a bad mood if you got a good
night's sleep
if you don't do you
what I'm saying is Mr Lindell [__]
oh dude just yo pressure
hey dude don't call my pillows lumpy man
I swear to God this guy's a rapper go
ahead no I'm pissed yep I understand you
know go when you're saying what oh dude
I don't even know what the [__] how did
it like what's with the lumpy pillows
like why how did that even come up you
know this is just a clip but wow Michael
indela just [__] absolutely crushing
Under Pressure but also applying
pressure we love it I love [__] my
pillows dude and I love Michael and Dell
so there we go